So this is how the Admin dashboard looks
after you first get your tracking ID.
We're going to close this window,
just have some information,
you can read it if you want,
I'm going to close it.
So we're currently in the Admin tab and
if you click this button here.
This arrow, left-pointing arrow, that
expands the Admin dashboard for you.
And you see up here these tabs tell
you which dashboard you're in.
Currently we're in the Admin dashboard.
So the overall account is Whats for
dinner, and
within that account,
we can have multiple properties.
But right now we only have one property,
DinnerApp.
So basically, DinnerApp is our app.
So if you click Property Settings,
this pretty much takes you to
the settings for the property.
This is where you come if you
want to find your tracking code.
Here you see your Tracking ID.
You can also go to
tracking code down here.
This is where you started out, remember.
So Google Analytics was
originally designed for websites.
Before there ever were any Android apps.
It's still a great tool for
tracking website data, but
it's become an equally amazing tool for
tracking mobile app data too.
But there are still parts of
the Analytics dashboard that haven't yet
let go of their origins as a tool for
websites.
The icon here, .js, is taken
from the web usage of Analytics.
Websites use JavaScript code
to talk to Analytics, but for
mobile apps, of course,
JavaScript code is not needed.
Don't worry, it's just an icon.
So to get back to
the overall Admin dashboard,
you press this button here,
the arrow I mean.
Let's take a look at the views section.
By default, you get a view
called All Mobile App Data,
which, you guessed it, tracks all
the data from your mobile app.
You can add more views if you like,
and set up filters.
But one view will serve us just fine for
now.
When you have some data to view
you can use the Reporting tab
here to explore the ways that
Users are using your app.
No Users yet, but
that's not a surprise because we haven't
hooked the app up to Analytics yet.
To get back to the admin dashboard,
go to the Admin tab.